pour ce début d'émission on va
s'adresser aux feignasse qui nous
regardent et je sais qu'il y en a il y
en a beaucoup des phenias qui nous
regardent TF1 a fait le sujet pour vous
en 2023 on pourra avoir 64 jours de
repos en en opposant seulement 26 mois
manger
que c'est moi
manger ma banane tout de suite la plage
si vous êtes une feignasse doublée d'une
pince ce sujet et pour vous continuez à
noter au mois de mai par exemple 4 jours
sont fériés et si vous prenez du mardi 2
au vendredi 5 soit 4 jours vous aurez 10
jours de repos d'affilée donc le Maroc
balaye ce qui me fait marqué à la
télévision algérienne c'était Coupe du
Monde l'équipe d'Espagne loupe trois tir
au but éliminé en 8e de finale face à
qui on sait pas c'est pas c'est
absolument magique alors ce week-end
pour la première fois ils ont mentionné
je les ai ils ont mentionné le score
mais ils ont des courses le directeur
général du combovia visuel public
algérien a été licencié regardez cette
présentatrice marocaine visiblement très
perturbée le Maroc a donc sorti
l'Espagne au Turc au tir au bit au tir
au but en 8e de finale de ce Mondial
qatari
autant vous dire que l'Algérie ne
suivait pas la Coupe du Monde du Maroc
sur la télé algérienne c'est très
compliqué il y a des tensions notamment
sur le Sahara occidental qui se
retranscrit quand on dit que le foot est
pas politique vous voyez il y a eu
aucune violence marocaine au Maroc ok la
police marocaine fait peut-être plus
peur il y a eu aucune violence des
français au Maroc ok il y a eu aucune
manifestation anglaise ou portugaise en
France OK et il y a eu globalement
effectivement ça c'est ce que disent la
presse globalement il n'y a pas eu de
drame en France mais il y a quand même
eu des incidents la question c'est le
coup fait-il du bien au moral des
Français non mais ça fait du bien au
moral mais ça va c'est pas ça qui va ni
chauffer les classes les plus modestes
ni remplir le sac de course
fasse plaisir aux gens que ça fasse
plaisir aux gens d'accord mais la
réalité c'est on prend les français pour
des débiles Thomas avec le froid là vous
n'êtes pas enrhumé vous
Thomas
bonjour
vous ne me trouverez pas parmi les
supporters chauvins exacerbés je
garderai la neutralité qui s'y a notre
métier oui car nous ne devons pas
prendre parti nous ne sommes pas des
éditorialistes y compris sur le football
ce match à venir entre la France et le
Maroc doit être équilibrée à condition
qu'on les découpe quand je vois ce qui
se passe dans Paris après un match comme
ça en fait Paris se transforme au
moindre plaisir en guérilla urbaine vous
voyez ici c'était la joie l'allégresse
le partage la convivialité la belle
émotion et à Paris on casse les abrévus
on casse tout pour se dire [ __ ] c'est
super la vie est belle quand on frite la
gueule je pense qu'il faut pas prendre
les français pour les abrutis ils
regardent les matchs ils sont contents
mais ils n'oublient pas pour autant la
réalité de leurs problèmes c'est ça les
détourne ça détourne un peu leur
attention mais je ne crois pas que ça
fasse du bien au moral parce que les
Français c'est des adultes c'est des
adultes
c'est pas les jeux
les Français les Français sont
suffisamment de Coupe du Monde
Laurent Delahousse hier soir France 2
une soirée de Liège qui était marquée
par des incidents notamment sur les
Champs-Élysées à Paris d'ailleurs
également à Lille ou encore à Marseille
à la clé 170 interpellations
alors faut dire aux gens que
l'information elle n'est jamais
objective regardez les bandeaux qu'ils
mettent en bas de l'écran victoire du
Maroc des violences gâchent la fête qui
se change en je ne dis pas que
naturellement un musulman ne puisse pas
quelle solution non mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est par exemple sur les
Champs-Élysées samedi soir il y a pas de
supporters français dire que aucun
supporter français ne célébrait la
victoire française il y avait que des
supports normalement c'était aussi
pourquoi pourquoi
le débat est ouvert voici 20 secondes de
ce qui s'est passé sur les
Champs-Élysées samedi soir vers 23
heures
la France
[Applaudissements]
a vraiment un mot
Nadia
Francia Brasil et ce Navidad en test de
Navidades
un brin de sport collectif ont réussi ou
la France est sur le toit du monde non
il faut arrêter
du monde en football c'est tapé dans une
baballe qu'est-ce que tu veux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et même après la défaite les anglais
sont restés hyper fair-play
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]